Tracy you're famous and you're wealthy
so we know you know more than most
people when do you predict this will all
be over seriously when can we go out
again and enjoy life when will this end
that's what we say about the Knicks I
know we say the same thing I didn't
agree you sitting side by side courtside
Knicks game you say the same thing to me
we'll listen be patient I'm really glad
I got to talk to you today because I see
you have a positive attitude buddy gotta
stay positive I know this truth she'll
pass to the nurses and the doctors and
the first responders and everybody
involved make you my hero I love you
keep working hard we need you and I
really that's coming from my heart
[ __ ] show business these people are out
there man you're on the front line
dealing with this [ __ ] and to the
scientists that's trying to really
quickly come over the cure we here we
waiting we here we waiting everyone is
trying to do their part everybody
government everybody's trying to do
their part cuz like I've been saying
around my whole [ __ ] life since my
father died of AIDS when I was 19
what affects one of us affects us vol
this is the equalizer I'm gonna [ __ ] how
much money you got or what color you got
you going to so we all got to stick
together
this [ __ ] is by design this is God's
design that bring us closer to him and
not further away I still love you when
this [ __ ] is over I can't wait to hug
you and Robin [ __ ] all that DAP into the
elbow [ __ ] I can't wait to get next to
you I'll hug you Alec like I always did
this [ __ ] is so not normal to me you
know I love you and you Robin you know
that whenever we see each other we hug
each other that's crying oh it's love
you back there so everybody start with
the blaming start with the getting angry
with each other in supermarkets cuz how
are we gonna fix this I was gonna get
around that when it's over I don't know
I'm doing my part as a comedian keeping
the world laughing while this is going
on that's all so my thing is i'ma run
run my race and love everybody like I
always been doing
I don't get what color you are or what
cream or what economic status you got I
love you and everybody please stay safe
out there and stay home so your
quarantine watch the last og Tuesday
1035 east in time and enjoy your life
look at you oh we love you look at you
man so wear your gloves and can I
applaud that can I applaud that speech
right now can I applaud that